welcome back to cbs warnings a cbs news
investigation finds that online threats
targeting federal authorities spiked
after the fbi search at mar-a-lago u.s
marshals say the number had already been
consistently rising since last year when
they say they dealt with 4 500 threats
against federal judges law enforcement
says that tensions rose after the
january 6 riot in 2021 and the supreme
court decision on abortion rights this
year
senior investigative correspondent
catherine herridge has more for us now
very concerning stuff catherine good
morning
good morning tony law enforcement and
security sources tell cbs news the surge
in credible online threats against the
fbi and federal judges is spilling over
with real world consequences
after the fbi executed the search
warrant in mar-a-lago protests swelled
outside the resort and explicit threats
surged online was the search of
mar-a-lago a tipping point i believe so
as a cyber threat investigator simon who
asked us not to use his last name for
security reasons searches online for
domestic terror threats sharing his
findings with federal law enforcement
we're seeing a major uptick in threats
any public figure is a viable target for
these people and it knows no political
affiliation simon and his team at the
washington-based research group memory
compiled this 90-page report most
content to graphic for broadcast some of
the terms are fbi or scum three-letter
agencies need to be cleansed eliminated
they'll die for treason
this is really serious language we're
seeing threats like this on a daily
hourly basis there's a very real risk of
law enforcement officers being hurt or
killed as a result of these threats
within days of the mar-a-lago search
authorities say 42-year-old ricky shiver
wearing body armor and carrying an ar-15
style rifle tried to breach the fbi
visitor center in cincinnati
[Music]
before he was killed in a standoff with
authorities is the attack on the fbi in
cincinnati the new normal i think so i
think it's moving in that direction
threats now go beyond law enforcement to
federal judges threats are real people
really have intent to harm folks
and they will they will carry it out
roberto robinson is deputy director of
the u.s marshals service his team
protects more than 2700 federal judges
including bruce reinhardt who signed off
on the fbi's mar-a-lago search warrant
was this a case where as soon as people
knew who the florida judge was the
threat started yes so it was almost
immediate absolutely robinson told us
reinhardt's address was posted online a
tactic called doxing is it one of the
leading concerns with federal judges i
would say so yes this is the first time
cameras had been inside the intelligence
center the marshals launched last year
to track online threats before this we
didn't have it and it was almost
reactive which is not good especially in
today's climate so we have taken a
proactive approach
in june 26-year old nicholas roski was
charged with attempted murder after
allegedly traveling to supreme court
justice brett kavanaugh's home with a
glock handgun ammunition and zip ties he
pleaded not guilty there was a real risk
of harm to justice kavanaugh absolutely
without a shadow of a doubt we're
thankful that we were in a strategic
location in which
we were able to stop anything before it
happened a madman
who i believe was targeting me because
of my position as a federal judge came
to my house two years ago the son of a
federal judge in new jersey was murdered
at her home
congress considered increasing funding
to pay for more deputy marshals but the
bill stalled do you have what you need
to protect federal judges i'll be doing
as a service if i didn't say we didn't
need anything but we were doing the best
we can with what we have now do you feel
stretched then we are pretty thin right
now we are trying to get academy classes
through so we can bring on more deputy
marshals but we could definitely use
more help for sure
given the already elevated threat the
marshal service told cbs news they often
see an uptick in online chatter during
elections and the midterms are only two
months away michelle
that they are an important story
catherine thank you